intéressant ce reportage
allô si je veux participer au Prix des
youtubeurs d'histoire et évidemment gros
je mets tout de suite
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour
parler d'un homme qui a su donner aux
Français un goût pour un aliment qui
nous met tous de bonne humeur et je
parle bien sûr ici 2 la pomme de terre
et cet homme c'est Antoine Augustin
Parmentier Parmentier est né en 1737 en
Picardie il est issu d'une famille très
modeste il va devenir apprenti
apothicaire à l'âge de 13 ans ses
parents ne l'avaient pas vraiment assez
d'argent pour l'envoyer au collège il
poursuit donc sa formation et va
s'engager dans l'âge dans l'armée à
l'âge de 20 ans en tant que pharmacien
bon entre nous s'il est parti dans
l'armée c'est pas pour faire la mec hein
c'est juste parce qu'il est passé
l'argent pour ouvrir sa propre pharmacie
mais au cours de la guerre des 7 ans qui
a duré de 1756 à 1763 Parmentier est
capturé par les Prussiens et comme tout
adversaire militaire les Prussiens
étaient très sadiques avec leurs
prisonniers et croyez donc les déprimés
en leur servant chaque jour une bouillie
de pommes de terre mais Parmentier
s'aperçoit que sa santé ne se dégrade
pas avec ce turbir avec ce tubercule il
élabore donc une théorie selon laquelle
cette plante pourra remplacer le pain en
France qui est donc l'aliment de base
des Français en cas de mauvaise raison
de retour en France il va commencer à
faire des recherches scientifiques sur
le danger potentiel de cette plante et
en 1786 Louis XVI donne une parcelle de
terrain à Neuilly préparer pour pouvoir
commencer les plantations de pommes de
terre Parmentier va tout mettre en
oeuvre pour convaincre et mettre de son
côté les plus grands scientifiques de
son temps comme Lavoisier ou Benjamin
Franklin
le 24 août 1786 Parmentier se rend à
Versailles pour offrir les premières
fleurs de pommes de terre au roi c'est
ainsi qu'elles fit son apparition sur la
table royale en connaissant à vif succès
et en toute humilité il décide de nommer
ses plantes les parmentières reste
encore à convaincre la population
paysanne que les patates sont
inoffensives Parmentier lui serrant le
génie du 18e siècle il va élaborer une
stratégie qui consiste à placer des
gardes inutiles autour d'un terrain
militaire a connu plantation de façon à
montrer aux Français que les patates ont
de la valeur les vols de tubercule se
multiplient surtout durant la nuit mais
les paysans sont déçus par le par leur
goût ne sachant comment les préparer
Parmentier va donc publier plusieurs
mémoires pour promouvoir les vertus
nutritionnelles de la pomme de terre
pour l'homme bah en gros c'est comme des
leaderset bon après je peux encore vous
parler de Parmentier des jours si on
s'attarde sur sa biographie pour plus
d'impôts rendez-vous sur Wikipédia pour
résumer on peut comparer les actions de
Parmentier pour instaurer la pomme de
terre dans nos assiettes comme une
campagne de pub sponsorisée par un
important investisseur Louis XVI
l'objectif de la petit carré est simple
à stopper la famine avec un nouvel
aliment clé pour les Français Paris
tenue malgré un groupe pétage de plomb
du tiers état quelques années plus tard
et vous savez quoi il a réussi à
survivre et aujourd'hui on peut se
rendre compte avec du recul que les
pommes de terre ont une place très
importante dans notre vie à la hauteur
de ce que souhaitais Parmentier bon
allez merci de m'avoir écouté
ma série m'attend
[Musique]